at upstate New York where Syracuse
University is taking action after a
series of racist and anti-semitic
incidents were reported on campus they
include a racist manifesto that was
reportedly sent to cellphones dozens of
student protesters have been staging a
sit-in in response and yesterday the
Chancellor agreed to several but not all
of their demands Adriana Diaz is on
campus there Adriana
good morning as I understand that this
is not the first time there's been an
issue there well Tony this latest string
of incidents began earlier this month
but as you said this isn't the first
time the university has had to deal with
racism last year a fraternity was
suspended after a video showed members
making racist and sexist comments now
students at the sit-in in the building
behind me say the university's latest
response is not enough after seven days
of 24-hour protests Syracuse University
Chancellor Kent syverud reassured
students about their concerns I think
we're in a key moment at this university
and a key moment to address serious
issues in the nation as well as this
university in a positive way in just the
past week there have been nine reported
incidents targeting black Asian and
Jewish students including graffiti of a
swastika over the weekend one student
told officials the n-word was yelled at
her the school said members of a
fraternity were involved which the
organization denied still that
fraternity was suspended and all
fraternity activities this semester
canceled the n-word has been an issue
here yes it's like a definite issue
student protesters would only agree to
interviews if we concealed their
identity we're not asking the university
to solve the issue of systemic racism
because we understand that the
university can't stop students from
acting out and doing things like this
but making our experience as comfortable
and normal as possible racism allegedly
infiltrated the library Monday night
when a white supremacist manifesto
written by the New Zealand mosque
shooter was air-dropped to cell phones
in the library yesterday afternoon the
Chancellor agreed to some of the
protesters demands like allocating at
least 1 million dollars a diversity
curriculum strengthening consequences
for hate speech and
and dating diversity training for all
faculty the university is now working
with local and federal investigators no
student should have to go through that
no citizen should have to go through
that and we understand the level of
concern that our students have now an
anonymous donor has offered $50,000 in
an award for information about who's
behind these incidents student
protesters told us that they think the
Chancellor's responses to their demands
lacks specificity the Chancellor is
holding a community forum tonight Tony
no idea Jenna thank you very much I mean
the best-case scenario is that someone
thinks they're being funny in the worst
case is very bad in the other oh it's
very troubling and we know students
black and white from Syracuse say this
is not who they are yeah this is not
what his dad's here whether they can
track that that air-dropped message in
the library I wonder about diversity
training I really do wonder what exactly
happens in that in those situations kind
of difference in me yeah I wonder how
effective that really is all right
Adriana thank you very much